hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel
and today i'm gonna tell you guys the
story
of how i almost got my dad like in
trouble
with what is that those people called
that like
will take kids out of bad situations
like dcfs i think
before i start do not forget to like oh
[ __ ]
like comment and subscribe every
subscriber helps me
move out of my parents house you guys
already know
i'm trying to get out of here oh and
don't forget to follow my instagram
i'll do like polls for the different
like songs i'm gonna do for the week so
you guys should definitely follow me on
instagram
my dad like he's a great dad i got no
ill will he had
he had no reason to have a cops called
on him right
but what happened was it was my 10th
birthday party
it was a surprise part it was pretty
cool um
when i was little there were three
floors in my house
um we had to go
from the top floor to the basement
without getting tagged by my dad
and everything was going well right um
i saw an opening to get to the basement
without my dad
tagging me so i turned the corner i'm
sprinting
right and all of a sudden i lose my
footing from under me
because the stairs were carpet and i
land like imagine this is my foot
i land on my foot like this so my foot
snaps and i broke three bones twice in
my foot so i had six breaks and then i
landed on my ankle and i broke that too
and i was screaming my head off like i
can't even remember the pain because i
was 10
and i'm 24 now so it's like 14 years ago
but
what i do remember is just like
that being the worst pain i ever
experienced but
i don't really remember it now but
i remember it being painful but i don't
remember the pain
is that weird i don't know anyways
when i get to the hospital this is where
i went wrong
when i got to the hospital
they asked me like what happened right
um
i tell them what happened i said i was
going
i was running from my dad and
i really didn't want him to catch me i
really didn't want him to get me
and then i fell down the stairs
and got hurt and like at this point the
doctors are like looking at me
for like bruises and [ __ ] which like i
always had as kids i'm super pale
it kind of looks like i have bruises
anyway you know what i mean and then
they asked me like
where is your dad now and we knew this
before the party but my dad was in india
like he was on a flight to india and
that's what i told them i was like
my dad he's in india and to them
it like literally looks like he's
fleeing the country for like abusing us
which he didn't at all he was such a
like he literally changed his whole work
trip so he could be there
and i had this man my mom had to like
talk to the doctors and like calm them
down and really assure them
that we were not being abused
but i felt kind of bad at hindsight i
was 10 though i didn't know the
difference
so that's how i almost got the cops
calling my dad
the first time but the second time i
actually did this another time but not
to my dad
it was and this was even worse because
the cops like
actually came i'm saying a common
denominator here
was me number two
was so my parents own a software company
and one of their employees his name is
bruce
and he kind of like i'm not even gonna
lie he
looked sketchy like if i had to give
someone
like he just looked kind of creepy like
chainsmoker and his 40s like i don't
know how to describe it he just
the look didn't help him but he wasn't
like he was super nice and
he lived in indiana my parents lived in
chicago
and one of my favorite like cousins
lived in
indiana so sometimes he would drive me
to my cousin's house like if i wanted to
spend a weekend there because
he would travel back and forth well on
the way
this lady asked me she's like
because she saw i was like with him and
he looks kind of sketchy she's like
how do you know him um
i think i was younger than 10 at this
point
um so actually i don't know
like what i meant was
i knew that my parents like knew him
but she kept asking me if he was like
related to me and i was like no
like i knew he wasn't my uncle i knew he
wasn't my cousin
but i just didn't know how he was
related to me
i kept telling her that i guess it
freaked this lady out so she ended up
calling the actual police
and they couldn't get a hold of my
parents at the time because they were
like doing something
so i ended up like being in police
custody
and so did he for a couple hours
oh because he was being nice and
dropping me off my cousin's house
that might have been the last time i
went we were on like trips as a kid
we had like a lot of close calls over
the years like
i definitely got left at a couple gas
stations i'm not salty about it but
i'm not excited about it either i only
come
i'm a gas station um
like my family's on a road trip um they
literally like
we're driving off um i like
call my mom oh my mom you locked me at
the gas station
well that's what i wanted this at but
before i could even talk
she's like hannah like why are you
calling me from the back of the car like
and i'm like mom and she just keeps
going i let her go off
oh my mom i'm at the gas station
they're like five minutes left so they
just
turned around another time
my sister someone forgot to pick her up
from practice so she literally just
walked home
and it was like 20 minutes by car away
so she just started walking home
at like 10 years old my parents again
had to call the cops
i think i'm done eating so it's a little
too much
food for me
but yeah that's my story time on how i
almost got two
different people in trouble with the
police
my bad anyways if you like these story
times i'm kind of like
experimenting with these on my channel
if you like them
don't forget to leave a comment let me
know if you like them leave a like
subscribe
and i will talk to you guys next time